so I have a question if you owe a
billion dollars are you a billionaire
now sure Alex Jones has been ordered to
pay close to a billion dollars but this
is great news for Alex Jones he's
finally going to get that real
bankruptcy that he's been angling for
for all this time total 120 million
dollars
that's because the kinetic Jury has
found the Jones and infowar should pay
965 million dollars to people who
suffered from his false claim that the
Sandy Hook Elementary School shooting
was a hoax Robbie Parker the father of a
six-year-old girl named Emily who was
murdered that day said quote all I can
really say is that I'm just proud that
what we were able to accomplish was just
to Simply tell the truth and it
shouldn't be this hard and it shouldn't
be this scary well Parker gave his
heartbreaking statements Jones was live
on Infowars calling the verdict
hilarious telling his audience that he'd
never pay these people a single penny
and ask his fan base for donations
because
of course so the real question is will
this info hole finally have to pay up or
what now here's the background on this
case the Connecticut verdict is right on
the heels of a Texas jury verdict
awarding millions of dollars to the
parents of other children killed in the
massacre in both cases Jones did not
defend the case on the merits and the
courts entered default judgments against
him because of all kinds of shenanigans
on Jones's part he effectively refused
to comply with Discovery in all of these
cases the lawsuit stems from Infowars
broadcast about the shooting at Sandy
Hook Elementary School in 2012 that
killed 20 first grade children six
Educators and wounded two others the
plaintiffs included the relatives of
five children and three Educators killed
in the mass shooting plus an FBI agent
who was one of the First Responders to
the scene as the plaintiffs in this case
pointed out quote overwhelming and
indisputable evidence shows exactly what
happened at Sandy Hook Elementary School
on December 14 2012. 26 children and
Educators were shocked by a lone youth
armed with an AR-15 now despite all the
evidence that 26 people lost their lives
that day Jones broadcast lies about
Sandy Hook for over five years on his
Infowars news program Jones and Infowars
contributors said that the entire thing
was a hoax staged by the the government
in order to take away the audience's
guns Jones and his contributors said
things like the massacre might really be
a hologram or an illusion that it was
the fakest thing since the three dollar
bill and that other Sandy Hook families
were paid to actually fake their loved
one's deaths now the league play tip in
the Connecticut case was Erica Lafferty
the daughter of school principal Don
Lafferty hawksbrung who was murdered by
the same gunman as the Sandy Hook
children now the plaintiffs completed
four causes of action against Jones
Invasion privacy negligent and
intentional infliction of emotional
distress violations of Connecticut
unfair Practices Act uh katpa c-u-t-p-a
and defamation now the case eventually
went to trial but only on Damages Jones
had already lost a liability phase
because of repeated refusals to respond
to the Court's orders and to participate
in the discovery process now Jones
constantly whines about the the legal
system and a supposed Grant conspiracy
to deny him the right to do process
because these wines bring him viewers
and help him sell supplements that are
basically just trucker speed however in
reality Jones wasn't denied due process
he simply refused to fully defend the
case and engage in the discovery process
or listen to the Court's orders and as
we've discussed many times on this
channel a slap lawsuit is filed by
someone in order to silence and
intimidate people for their speech and
slap suits are genuinely bad since they
can allow powerful people to stifle Free
Speech simply by draining the Target's
financial resources and when the
Sandhill Survivor Sue Jones he filed
motions to dismiss the plaintiff's
complaints pursuant to Connecticut's
anti-slap Statute in order to respond to
the Motions the planes have to move for
limited Discovery and Jones opposed it
Jones and the plaintiffs went back and
forth for more than a year with Jones
usually asking for more time and the
court giving him that time eventually
Jones stopped complying with the
discovery orders entirely even though
the court had agreed to some of his
requests about limiting the scope of
that Discovery but finally in 2021 the
trial Court said that Jones simply
refused to comply with Discovery orders
so judge Bellis criticized Jones
attorney for providing only sanitized
inaccurate Financial records and showed
a callous disregard for her repeated
rulings to provide complete analytics
data she found Jones's attorney's
actions were quote not just careful but
constituted a pattern of obstructive
conduct quote neither the court nor the
parties can expect Perfection when it
comes to the Discovery process what is
required however and what all parties
are entitled to is fundamental fairness
that the other side produces information
which is within their knowledge
possession and power and that the other
side meets its continuing duty to
disclose additional and new material and
so when Jones refused the judge entered
default judgment against Jones default
judgment is a binding judgment in favor
of the other party based on some failure
to take action by the other party in
other words the Court ruled in favor of
the plaintiffs by default but after
liability was established by default the
Connecticut case went to trial on how
much damages Jones had to pay each of
the plaintiffs presented evidence about
what they expect experienced as they
listened to Jones lie about the Sandy
Hook shooting how it impacted their
health jobs and lives William Sherlock's
wife Mary was a school psychologist
killed at Sandy Hook he testified that
he was harassed online by people
claiming that his wife never existed
people made up conspiracy theories about
Sherlock saying he was involved with his
Shooter's father or that he was part of
a shadowing network of financiers with a
motive to create a hoax Robert Parker
testified that less than one day after
his daughter's murder Jones went on his
show and called Parker an actor later
that same night hateful comments were
posted to the Facebook memorial page for
Emily Parker said he removed Emily's
Facebook memorial page weeks after the
shooting because of harassment was just
too much to control Vicki Soto was a
teacher killed in the attack her son
said that after President Obama praised
his mother people commented on a
Facebook post claiming that he wasn't
real the family wasn't real and that his
mother didn't exist plaintiffs in this
case argued and the court recognized
that Jones intended to activate his
audience not satisfied with just
misinforming the audience Jones urged
his viewers to investigate the situation
on their own millions of people watch
and listen to Infowars for some reason
and some of them harassed stalked and
targeted the Sandy Hook families and
First Responders The plaintiffs
recounted Strangers showing up their
homes recording them shouting about
conspiracy theories Mark Braden said
that Jones fans urinated on his
seven-year-old son's grave even
threatening to dig up the coffin
hawksbone Lafferty testified that people
sent rape threats to her house during
the litigation Jones also turned his ire
on the judge and the lawyers involved in
the case asking his fans to do his dirty
work he said quote to the Patriots that
are left and 4chan and achan and to
anybody that's a patriot I'm under
attack if they bring me down they'll
bring you down I just have faith in you
I'm under attack and I summon the mean
War I summon all of it against the enemy
the FBI concluded that Fringe political
conspiracy theories very likely
motivated some domestic extremists
citing the pizzagate conspiracy and
Jones's Sandy Hook lies the plaintiff's
legal team told the jury that Jones knew
the likely impact of his actions but
that he just didn't care in close using
arguments plaintiff's attorney Chris
mate said quote when every single one of
these families were drowning in grief
Alex Jones put his foot right on top of
them but now we know the end result here
we have a partial verdict The Alex Jones
verdict was only on compensatory damages
the jury awarded plaintiff's a whopping
965 million dollars and the breakdown is
as follows 36 million to Bill Sherlock
90 million to former FBI agent William
eldenburg 55 million dollars to David
and Francine wheeler 57.6 million and
73.6 million to Mark and Jacqueline
bartany 81.6 million and 73.6 million
respectively to Ian and Nicole Hockley
231 million dollars to the family of
slain teacher Victoria lay Soto 121
million dollars to Robert Parker now on
top of these compensatory damages the
judge will determine whether Jones owes
punitive damages next month now what's
the difference between punitive and
compensatory damages well competitor
damages are designed to compensate the
victim's losses whereas punitive damages
are designed to punish bad actors
compensatory damages pay plaintiff back
for losses they cover things like
medical bills hospital bills future
medical expenses and lost pay from
missing work these damages are generally
not capped which is why the verdict was
so high now on the other hand states
often have caps on punitive damages what
can I say businesses often Lobby to
prevent huge punitive Awards because
they don't like paying huge punitive
Awards and this is often what's
contemplated by the term tort reform and
under Connecticut Common Law Courts have
the discretion to award punitive damages
when the evidence shows a reckless
indifference to the rights of others or
an intentional or wanted violation of
those rights this determination is made
by the judge common law punitive damages
in Connecticut are limited to the cost
of bringing the litigation including
plaintiff's attorney's fees however the
Connecticut unfair Trade Practices Act
claim opens Jones up to a bigger
punitive damages award the punitive
damages award under the Connecticut
unfair Trade Practices Act are not
capped in order to support an award of
punitive damages under that act quote
the evidence must reveal a reckless
indifference to the rights of others or
intentional and wanton violation of
those rights a plaintiff doesn't even
need to plead or prove compensatory
damages in order to recover punitive
damages under the ACT but since the
application of punitive damages under
that act is so broad the Connecticut
Supreme Court has noted that it creates
an essentially Equitable cause of action
in other words it's very good for the
plaintiffs in Connecticut if jurors find
that punitive damages are appropriate
the judge then determines that amount
this will happen at a separate Hearing
in November Jones characterized his
stance as a boycott of the trial since
his lack of compliance with court rules
and procedures has resulted in two
default judgments and two big verdicts
you might think that he would change
strategies for punitive damages but he
is of course more likely to double down
on his losing strategy
[Music]
now so far all the money awarded to the
plaintiffs in the Jones case is for
compensatory damages and although Jones
will certainly appeal judges are often
reluctant to reduce a jury award
especially in a state like Connecticut
which has no caps on compensatory
damages so it's possible that the awards
will be reduced on appeal but they won't
be automatically reduced as punitive
damages often are now I should also note
that often juries are not told about
limits on punitive damages so they don't
shift what would normally be a punitive
damage into a compensatory damage award
and some have speculated here that
following along the limits in Texas on
punitive damages it's possible that this
jury overloaded the compensatory damages
in this particular case but at the
moment there's no way to know juries are
a black box now Jones also complicated
his appeal by refusing to put on a
defense in the damages phase he could
have called his own Witnesses and
testified himself like he did in Texas
by doing so there would have been
evidence on the record showing why the
damages should have been lower the jury
could have considered whether Jones was
contrite whether he made a formal
apology whether he did the things to
ensure that Infowars contributors won't
make crazy claims like this in the
future but since he did not put on his
own evidence the appeal is going to be
less straightforward now as for
mitigating factors Jones has not helped
his case by going on a show and stating
that the lawsuits are trying to stop him
from talking about Parkland and Uvalde
Alex Jones is suggesting that maybe
there's a conspiracy going on in those
two horrific mass shootings now this
kind of rhetoric is probably not going
to help him show that he's sorry that
he's learned his lesson or any of the
things he half-heartedly argued in the
Texas case now the bigger question that
everyone wants to know is will the
plaintiffs ever get paid Jones says he
only has about two million dollars to
his name yet Jones raised millions of
dollars after the Texas verdict came out
experts testified that Infowars is
between 100 and 250 million dollars and
plaintiff's lawyers promised to chase
Jones to the end of the Earth to collect
on the Judgment so how will they do that
well lawyers will have to connect Jones
to the many shell companies that he's
set up for in for Wars and his
Associated businesses they'll probably
argue that even though these entities or
corporations and llc's the companies and
Jones are legally the same entity in the
corporate veil should be pierced if that
eventually happens Jones's personal
assets could be seized as well as the
corporate Assets Now all of this
implicates the bankruptcy court too as
we've discussed before Jones and his
companies have filed for bankruptcy
protection but Jones has suffered some
setbacks a bankruptcy judge removed the
lawyer and chief restructuring officer
for free speech systems the parent
company of Infowars after they failed to
disclose prior connections to Jones the
judge also directed the bankruptcy
trustee to examine Free Speech systems
financial affairs operations and Insider
relationships this happened after
creditors complained to the court that
the company was hiding its assets
through complex corporate structures as
I discussed in my last Jones video a
company owned by Jones's parents pqpr
Holdings says it's a major creditor of
free speech systems Jones allegedly owes
mom and pop 54 million dollar the
bankruptcy judge found that there has
been quote a lack of Candor by the
companies and their lawyers and this
means that the bankruptcy case is
already traveling the same path as the
Texas and Connecticut lawsuits now Liz
Dye is a fantastic journalist who has
been following the Jones bankruptcy
where most of the action is likely to
take place in the future yes she is a
complete masochist so let's ask her Liz
what effect is this verdict likely to
have on the rest of the bankruptcies
yesterday Jones promised his viewers
that they could shower him with cash and
not have to worry that any of the money
would go to the Sandy Hook victims the
reality is that his company FSS is in
bankruptcy and he doesn't really have
control over it anymore and because Alex
Jones is Alex Jones he's done a bunch of
really shady things that mean he has
even less control than a normal debt or
would in bankruptcy the most egregious
thing he did was to have the company
sign two promissory notes for upwards of
50 million dollars right around the time
that he got defaulted in the Sandy Hook
cases so suddenly the company which
supplies his beet juice and male
Vitality pills remembered that it hadn't
billed FSS for years for products
supplied and so FSS owed the drug
supplier 50 million dollars at least in
theory so in 2021 FSS signed these two
notes and started shoveling mountains of
cash out the door to the drug Supply
light company the effect of the notes is
to make the drug Supply Company first in
line to get paid but it turns out that
the supplement company is owned in whole
by Jones and his parents through a
series of Nevada LLCs so what he's done
is effectively impoverished FSS and
claim all of its assets for himself
personally which is pretty convenient
months ago the Texas plaintiff sued
saying that the notes were fraudulent
transfers and also alleging that Jones
had made a lot of cash transfers to
himself from the company coffers so the
bankruptcy court is looking both at the
promissory notes and at those cash
transfers to see if they should be
clawed back so how much the plaintiffs
get paid here really depends on whether
the court tosses out the notes and Claws
back that cash from Jones himself
secondarily Jones claims a right to have
FSS indemnify him for any jury verdict
which would mean that he's not on the
hook personally for any of the money
owed to these plaintiffs and that would
be cool for him because he could loot
the company claim all of its assets were
owed to him personally and then free
from any personal liability he can go
and do the same thing somewhere else so
he can start schminfo wars and sell male
volatility pills there using the same
stick that he uses here so there are a
lot of moving Parts in this bankruptcy
and I think that's where most of the
action is going to wind up yes at this
point schminfo Wars sounds more
reputable than the original Infowars
definitely give Liz a follow on Twitter
now Alex Jones isn't personally in
bankruptcy yet it's going to be a fight
but his personal assets are likely to be
subject to this giant award and I should
probably make a video on this topic but
the way lawyers go after people's assets
when they're subject to court judgments
is a fascinating process in and of
itself you go through a whole lot of
attachment process to go after an
individual's salary bank accounts and
assets to satisfy the judgment and
there's a whole bunch of law on this
because the only thing lawyers love more
than winning a case is getting paid of
course Jones has tried to hide his
assets through his corporate entities
but the bankruptcy court was already
paying very close attention to these
companies because they are in bankruptcy
infowar's parent company Free Speech
systems is being monitored by the
Department of Justice appointed trustee
so when he Hawks collodial silver male
horse Vitality pills or whatever that's
going to go to the corporate entities
and it stands a good chance of going to
the plaintiffs before it ever goes to
Jones himself the plaintiffs in Texas
and Connecticut will be debtors in the
bankruptcy estate and they'll try to get
as much as they can lawyers are very
good at that and the court is watching
so things are bad for Alex Jones and
they're only going to get worse now I'm
not sure Alex Jones could even count to
965. let alone 965 million he's really
brushed up on his math and stem skills
with today's sponsor brilliant brilliant
is an online learning platform for stem
that replaces lecture videos with
Hands-On interactive lessons brillian is
for Curious Learners both young and old
professional and inexperienced you can
quickly learn to Ace your high school or
college math courses or just learn stuff
that you always wanted to know one of my
favorite courses is all about logic
something that Jones obviously never
studied Brilliance logic courses cover
liar and Truth teller riddles logical
fallacies machine logic and even some
strategic game theory logic is a crucial
skill that lawyers need every day and
Brilliant statistics and finance classes
are just as good now brilliant lets you
learn by doing rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures learning
through doing is scientifically proven
to be the most effective way to master a
new skill the courses have storytelling
interactive challenges and problems to
solve now you can sign up and start
learning for free today by clicking on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description the first 200
people to sign up will also get 20 off
their annual subscription so by clicking
on the link that's on screen or in the
description you'll get 20 off your
subscription to brilliant plus click on
that link really helps out this Channel
and after that click on this playlist
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court